The joe rogan experience.
So tell me what the fuck happened with Tracy Morgan.
I'll preface this.
I want to be safe and prefaces that my buddy Jay Moore does tell this on stage.
We have an agreement.
He's my friend.
He's not a thief.
Okay.
That's,
I just want,
I know that Jay is concerned about that,
but he told me he's not telling the story anymore.
And it did happen to me as long as,
I mean this is a true story is a true story.
It's a true story.
So as a young comic working in at the Boston Comedy Club,
we're in the door in New York,
in New York.
Yeah.
And I used to party with all the black comics because they well cause you like
to yeah.
And so we uh,
we used to have a good time.
And so then one night Tracy Morgan comes in,
this is when he starts to get back into standup after SNL.
So like when you were young comic in a new celebrity coming you like had to see
that shit had to,
so I go in and I watched Tracy set and it is not,
we have nothing in common.
He's doing observational material and his observational material is like,
oh right you okay?
Okay,
who remembers Vinca fucking bout a handball courts and I'm just like,
and he thinks that's a shared experience like losing a sock in the dryer,
right.
Everyone else.
And then he walks you through and he's like,
you would put that bitch up against the wall,
just pussy pop.
That bitch wouldn't even kiss.
So put your arm and your own stank and now you have a visualization of like
precious getting boxed out at a handball court,
making eye contact with passer by just getting her Bootsy blown out by Tracy
Morgan.
He goes on stage and he's like,
fucking,
yeah,
I hit that man.
I've got this new bit about my dick being so pretty.
Or you can soak it with the lights on,
which is a genius statement.
I never had a blowjob in the light,
but he just didn't word it right.
Right.
So
exactly what the lights are.
So he,
um,
so he goes,
he,
uh,
so then he goes,
oh,
you want to get hot?
And I was like,
yeah,
and because I'm a grown up and so we walk around the corner and he pulls out
this rack of a joint hands.
It to me,
hits it,
that gives it to me.
I hit it and it tastes like shit.
It tastes like sweat socks.
Like just,
just like,
and I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
And he's like,
oh,
you never smoked a sherm before?
And I was like,
what?
He's like,
show or baby angel does PCB you've never smoked shown before.
And I'm like,
you just given me fucking like,
how did you know who ever taught you how to get high?
So I panicked.
Bad,
like hardcore anxiety attack.
I go back to the club,
I'd go to this older black comic who's was and still is,
one of my good friends.
And I go,
hey man,
Tracy just gave me PCP.
He's like,
Oh,
oh,
let me tell you something.
Shawty.
Tracy done smoked PCP.
He's not fees fucking with you.
I was like,
when he's up,
he's going,
he's just smoking pot.
He's fucking with you though.
He's just getting in your head.
And I was like,
no,
he smoked PCP.
I'm feeling weird.
And he goes,
whatever you do shoty don't go to your house.
You hang out with us tonight.
So I'm like,
all right.
So I'd do my set,
I bomb.
We all go out and Tracy is in downtown Soho,
like debt,
right on house.
Tim Wright and he's in a club that,
it's like one of those railroad clubs where it goes all the way back.
You have to like walk down five spice,
a flight of five stairs to get to and he's in the back.
He's been there like 20 minutes and he is holding court with his shirt off.
Okay.
Shirt off.
Bottles of champagne covering his table.
There's other tables that have champagne on it.
He's buying it for them.
I buy her a bottle of champagne right now.
I've got a pretty Dick,
like just Eddie Murphy gave me this,
whatever the fuck you saying is like loud and boisterous.
So I sit at the table and I'm thinking I'm on PCP.
And I started ordering Heinikin separately from this wreck of a bar tab he has.
And so I'm getting Heinekens and then the whole night goes through,
it's kind of an interesting,
bizarre experience,
but like two o'clock in the morning and uh,
Tracy and the waitress comes up and she's got the bill and she puts it in front
of me cause I'm going to table with all black dudes.
So she thinks on their agent or lawyer or coach,
whatever I am.
So she gives me the bill and I see it and I'm like,
oh,
I can't.
And Tracy Morgan flips out and he goes,
oh,
what the fuck is that?
That's fucking racism.
You give it to him.
He works the God damn dog.
He doesn't new.
I not make any money on the rich mobile fucking here.
I'm on TV.
I'm the ritual,
the fuck.
And he flips the bottle of champagne table upside down.
Now the woman's like,
I'm sir.
And he goes,
hey.
And he takes his shirt and throws it in her face.
A bouncer comes up and he's like,
excuse me sir.
And Tracy just wham lays the guy in the biggest fight I've ever been in just
breaks out all over.
People are fighting,
jumping on,
and I think I'm on PCP.
So I walk out on Houseton and I start going,
this isn't happening.
This is the imaginary.
This is not real.
People are flooding out left and right.
And they're like,
dude,
that shit's going off trees.
He's got like four dudes on him.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
A minute later the doors kicked open and Tracy Morgan is launched out of the
club by the back of his neck and a seat of his pants just up onto the street
shirt on him.
No up on the street,
shirtless laying at my feet on the sidewalk.
Doors close.
Second later door's kicked back open and Tracy's shirt comes out,
end over end and lands on his head and it's silent.
And we're looking at Tracy like,
fuck,
this is crazy.
All of a sudden he looks up,
stands up,
takes his shirt,
snaps it,
and he goes,
now that's how you get out of paying a check.
This guy's crazy.
Like a Fox.
He fucking to walk in a $6,000 part,
Shit kicked out of the park.
It really did that.
That's awesome.
I mean,
did he ever have to pay for it whenever?
I have no idea.
I never,
I did.
Here's the thing,
I don't limit.
Only met Tracy wants that.
You don't hang out with a dude more than that.
Oh,
I would never leave that guy side.
I would have to be
all the time.
I never knew.
I never knew how to start.
I don't hear anything.
Brian.